les voilà dames et messieurs et charmant
futurs époux ml
marcheurs espèce de salopards tu disais
que tu étais mon meilleur ami qu'est ce
que vous faites ici
[Rires]
j'ai désolé c'est un événement privé
d'accord aux écoulons que les mariés on
a rencontré ces deux belles four au
mexique
le sel n'a pas un goût de sel je croyais
avoir été clair quand je vous ai dit
elles font bien leur boulot ça n'a rien
de clair vous nous avez drogué je
croisais aux drogues même pas en
vacances
écoutez on essaie de contenir
pourquoi tu leur as dit à bientôt ça
laisse la porte ouverte et ils sont tous
et je voulais pousser tout temps ça
n'empêche matière mais j'espère que tu
aimes les parties à kurt jackpot
et qu'on va quelque part
c'est le chaos
tout le week-end il n'y a que vous qui
compte et j'aime bien quand et 17
minutes
mesdames et messieurs qui sont marcus et
moi on s'est croisé au mexique est la
pièce que notre bâtiment c'est le
meilleur mariage auquel j'ai jamais
assisté mais c'est bouteille sur la tête
ils plaisant bébé le blanc est la
bouteille s'est vite
non